we see by the end of season two belly
and Jeremiah really decide we're gonna
give it a go what am I thinking
[Music]
Chris let's start with you do you think
she made the right choice
well I mean I I think it's not for me to
say I think of course she did if someone
is following their heart I don't think
they can be making a wrong decision
uh poetry yes and I think I brought into
my hand this morning
um
but but truly I I I think it's not for
me to
judge someone else's decision even if
it's a character and I think
um
if you yeah what I said before the the
fruit stuff I felt
good about that decision in that moment
but
in that moment
um
that is the person who
who is showing up for her in the way
that that she needs someone too and I
think in like episode six we see that
when Conrad and belly have a fight on
the beach that she really would have
fought for that relationship and it
doesn't seem like
maybe because he can't really express it
but in her
um from her point of view it doesn't
seem like he would fight for it the same
way
I loved each other
we did
I guess not enough
I think she's found someone who she she
loves and who will fight for her and her
relationship and who makes her happy
um so I think
in that moment yeah it's absolutely the
right thing for her
[Music]
how are you feeling about belly's choice
at the end of the season
oh man
um
you know I think it's I think it was
long overdue I mean two whole seasons
for for that to happen
um
um and so what what that does is makes
it special
um I think like people are gonna be uh
just excited to see what their
relationship is like but yeah I mean as
long as belly is following
um following her heart
um I think that that you know it's
important it's important to stay true to
who you are well I am team Valley
through and through and I know you are
too
say is it fair to say in this moment
that your team Jeremiah if I say
anything it will be used for any sort of
reference so I think
like any time in the future
um okay I'm I'm always firmly team belly
and I think in this moment belly's team
Jeremiah
so do without what you will
okay that's fair I like that you're like
I'm not I don't want any receipts coming
back to haunt me here yeah yeah I'm just
you know Sean Sean you're big bro and
your stamp of approval is so important
where's your heart at are you a Jeremiah
guy or are you holding out hope for
Conrad see that's that's that's the
thing I'm always given answer that's
disappointing to the fans uh hopefully
hopefully hopeful to other some of them
I'd like I'm I'm team hurt man I'm team
Lil Sis finding happiness you know what
do you say Joe I'm gonna get out of here
go play some video games leave the girls
to do their thing uh thanks but
um I'm gonna stay and see Bells play
there is a lot of Team Conrad girls and
boys out there who are maybe shedding a
tear or two by the end of season two I
would love for you to look in the camera
and address your your team Conrad fans
and maybe give them a message of Hope
how do you hope they're feeling by the
end of season two I mean look got it my
bad I didn't write it
um hold on you know I mean hopefully
we'll get to continue the story
um and if we do we've read the books
um you know there's still a whole other
book to this story so I I hope we get to
explore that
okay so team Conrad just hang in there
cross your fingers
yeah
I'm Pro Jeremiah I love it yeah
for any specific reason I just think
that like it's a more secure situation I
think that he's not gonna I don't think
he's gonna do her wrong
okay like it's so important to be best
friends with the person that you're also
in love with I think they have that I
think
he's Young
the time to explore and she's gotta go
where her heart takes her it could end
up being someone entirely different at
the end I love that Susanna is so
supportive of all of this I I don't know
as a mom I would be like please maybe
give my boys a break
how do you navigate all of that being
the supportive mom but like I want both
my kids to be happy no one's coming from
a bad place so I think I don't know I
think that's what that time in your life
is is about you better do it then
instead of when you're 30. it's a time
to find out who you are and part of that
is being with different people and
seeing different sides of yourself
they're kind boys bellies kind
yeah okay so someone had to have a like
a 0.0001 advantage in your heart just as
as Rachel as a fan I can't choose
between my between my boys
okay Jackie who has the Competitive Edge
right now in your heart oh
my I will not choose however I do see
why she would choose him at this point
that Jeremiah is very supportive and
dependable
um and also so cute so I can understand
where her mind is right now Elsie how do
you feel
yeah you know listen I I got nothing
against Jeremiah he's a wonderful boy
um what is it like I don't know it's
just like like I just feel it in my gut
I'm just like there's something about
Conrad and belly it's just like
you know it's like yeah I agree I mean
and I think that's what belly feels too
oh
yeah I don't know if we were like
friends with these people in real life
I'd if I was like friends with Bill I'd
be like go Jeremiah he's obviously the
smarter like more Steve choice but as a
fan of this show and like a fan of I
don't know like star-crossed lovers and
like Shakespearean tropes I think belly
I got red is is the move I think it
comes down to who's the best kisser and
only belly can tell us that
that's the best answer that's true not
only did Lola your character get a love
triangle but Sean yours did too
um really cool to see you and Taylor and
Milo but ultimately we really get to see
staylor win in the end of season two
[Music]
yeah
one thousand percent are you a Steeler
stand the way that we are I hope so I I
mean I I would like to think so I
definitely am I think that relationship
is just so much fun to craft this year
and the rain is beyond tremendous I love
her so much and I I hope people are
Teamsters just as much as as I am when I
crawl into my bed every night and go
I'm all for it I think that like
you know they
grew up together so like they've seen
each other in all of the awkward moments
of like childhood and teenager and I
think that like I think Conrad is to
belly what Stephen is a Taylor even
though she never you know expressed it
and she was too scared of being
vulnerable to like be like I really like
this person because I think she has a
huge fear of rejection
so you know being vulnerable is really
really hard for her she has a soft spot
for belly and she also has this like
amazing soft spot for Stephen I think
that he sees right through her you know
he's like he fully sees her for like who
she really is and I think that that
brings her a lot of comfort and allows
her to
um be more vulnerable where she wouldn't
have